やあ、みんなドーガンここに
いるから久しぶりに
日本についてのビデオを作ったんだけど、
ここに住んで
勉強したり、ここで英語を教え
たり、ここで家族を育てたりすることについて質問している人々から、Twitterで約100の質問がありました。
これらのいくつかを
試してみましょう。私は各質問に少し長すぎる傾向があるので、いつもより少し早くしようと
思います。最終的に得たアーティストである友人のイクトリからの最初の質問 ここで
留学しますので、
育休おめでとうございます。
奇妙なことに、私の現在の
質問は、異文化間のデートと関係に関して、どのように良い基盤を作成するかということです。
深刻なコミュニケーションの違いで共通点を見つけることは
、あなたの観点から興味深いと思います。
日本人と関係を持ちたいと思っている外国
人がたくさんいるので、非常に成熟し
た質問です。
外国人
と
の高揚感は、核心を突くようなことや、
うまく言えば
、ロマンチックな関係を持つことを考えている
ときだけ、楽観的なことを考えている
ときだけです。  「実際には将来的
に対立に見舞われるので
、そもそも非常に成熟し
た質問ですが、その意味
で、それぞれが話す言語で共通の基盤を持つ必要がある
と思いますが、何よりも
それは あなたがオープンで成熟していて、
あなたの両方がオープンで成熟しているなら
、日本人の
女の子とデートしたい、日本人の男性とデートしたい、というようなものではなく、この考え方と関係を築いていると思い
ます。
少なくとも
1 つの言語を流暢に話せる 関係
の最初にその人と座って、
私たちは異文化関係にあり
、  dそのため、私たち
が同じ背景から来て、
その考え方で再びそれに取り組み、非常に
オープンでコミュニケーションをとれば、おそらく起こらないであろう多くの困難に直面することになります. 人間関係に関しては非常に多くの要因があるため
、それがうまくいくかどうかを知っているとは言い難いです
が、
コミュニケーションが重要だと思い
ます.  「同じ
文化の出身です。非常に成熟した質問
です。その成熟した観点から、あなたは、
より
小さく、比較的国際化されていない都市で、双子のために学校のスラッシュライフなどをどのように見つけていますか?
子供ができたばかりで、東京にはたくさんの
選択肢があるみたいだけど、どうやっ
てバブルから離れているのか気になるから、多くの
人は知らないんだよね。これについて
は過去に何度か話したことがあるけど、別府
は 実際には間違いなくmor
東京よりも国際的であり、それは別府が最も高い濃度を持っているためであり
、
日本
のどの都市よりも外国人と日本人の比率が最も高いか、2番目に高い
ためです。
ここ
には大学があり、私は以前働い
ていましたが、学生の半分は
日本国外からの留学生です。彼らの
多くは卒業
してその間に滞在することになりますが
、
教員の半分もそうです。  apu の教師
も外国人で、スタッフの多くは
キャリア オフィスで働き、
私が以前行っていたように入学者募集の仕事をし
ているのと同じように、私のように再び国際的です。
彼らは学生としてアポに通ったり
、アプで働いたりして、最終的にはアポを離れてしまい
、
別府は
とても快適なので、別府にとどまります。
外国人
との交流に慣れているので、
外国人として住む街な
ので、外国人として市役所に行ったり、外国人
として別府のアパートを借りてみたりすると、
比較的合理的です。
まだ
お役所仕事
が多い.そもそもそれが日本の文化の特徴だと思うから.でも相対的に言えば
お役所仕事は少ない.なぜならあなたは外国人
だから
.
ここで子供を育てることに関しては知っていますが、
私がそのような長い
紹介をした理由
は、ここの教師は
混合の子供たちにも慣れ
ているからです。 公園
か何かで、
別の混合家族の
ように会います。ええと、いつもの
ように、この質問に答えるのは実際には非常に難しい
と思います。
あなたは次のような印象を受けて
いました.あなたは非国際都市で子供を育てるのはどんな感じかを尋ねようとしていたと思います.
しかし
、別府は
実際には非常に国際的な都市であるため
、私はそれには本当に答えることができません. この質問に少し触れたいの
ですが、私は日本のすべての主要な
インターナショナル スクールに通って
います。なぜなら、私が apu で働いていて、
生徒募集をしていたとき
、日本人の生徒が通っている学校に行くのが私の仕事だった
からです。 インターナショナル
スクール
に行って、そこに行く日本人学生を募集し
て、アプに来るように勧めるのが私の仕事だったので
、東京と横浜の私立インターナショナルスクールのような私立インターナショナルスクールに行った
ことがあります。
横浜、
大阪、
福岡も同様
です。面白いことに、彼らの多くは再びプライベートで
、年間 1 万 1500 ドルの
ようです。非常に高価であり
、非常に優れたサービスを提供しています。
教育ですが、日本は
現在深刻な人口危機に直面し
ているため、人口が減少していることはわかってい
ます。実際、別府のような場所
には、他の多くの種類の
小さな都市があり、一般的
に教室のサイズは非常に小さいため
、
カリキュラムの種類
は根本的に
異なりますが、公立の
日本語学校に通う場合は、非常に
パーソナライズされた経験を得ることができ
ます.
年間1万ドルですが、その環境
では、教室の20人の生徒のうちの1人のようなものかも
しれません。教師が
素晴らしい教師であったとしても、10人の生徒がいる公立学校についてまだ何か言いたいことがあると思い
ます.
先生は一人で、日本
の小さな都市にはそのような学校がたくさんある
ので
、考えるのに良い食べ物かもしれ
ません。 リカン
子供
が自分で旅行する文化についてどう思いますか 幼い子供が
一人で電車に乗ったり、食料品の買い物をしたり
食料品の買い物などに興味
があります アメリカではあまり一般的ではないときに、それ
に順応するのはどのようなものか興味があります 彼らは
まだ幼稚園に通っているので、基本的にどこにでも同行しなければならない年齢にまだあるので、バスに
飛び乗って好きなことをさせてあげることはできませ
んが、 私
が小さな街に住むのが好きな
理由としては、急いでいる人が少ないこと、
赤信号を無視する人が少ない
こと、子供を遊びに行かせるときに親として心配することが少ないことなどがあります。
初めてのことなので、
まだ完全に達成できていないので何とも言えませんが、
このような小さな都市に住むことで
、外国人としての私が双子を持つことで移行プロセスが容易になると思い
ます。違いはありますか? 彼らのそれぞれが現在どのように
言語を習得しているかについて
は、実際にはそうではありませんが、私たちはほとんど
家でほぼ完全に英語を
話していると言います.
私は非常に心配し
てい
ます.spの場合でも彼らが完全にバイリンガルであることを望んでいます.これ
は最近本当に当てはまります.
日本語がブレーキを踏む
ように頻繁に出てくるのを感じることができます.
正しい英語は何ですか.
というのは、
彼らが公立の日本語学校に通い
始め、彼らの日本語が
彼らの英語
をかなり上回り始めているからです。
できるだけ多くのケチャップを
かけて、家でドクター・スースの本を知っているようにたくさん読ん
で、2つの違いがあるかどうか尋ねましたが、
基本的に両方ともそうではありません
彼らの英語が彼らの英語を上回り始め
ているところから、彼らの日本語が
彼らの英語を追い越し始めているところから、私は彼らにできるだけ多くの英語
を教えるために最善を尽くしてそれに対抗しよ
うと
しています.
シニア ジュニア ヒエラルキー 若い
会社のオーナー
は、政府や
私が知っている人々に基づいて、政府やその
ような問題をどの
ように認識しています
か? それは
難しい それはただ多くの
人がそれをして
いるわけではないということだ
apu umでの仕事を辞めたときのように、周囲の人々からの躊躇や抵抗はあり
ません.私の周りには、apuをやめるべきではないと思っている人がたくさんい
ました.apuはa laの一部です.  rger
big japanese kind of um
whole jean
not company 正しい英単語が思い浮かびません 申し訳ありません
が、
彼らはあなたがまともな仕事を手に入れたように見えますが、私の目に
はまともな仕事ではありませんでした。
ええと、彼らは
少なくとも安定しているようでした.少なくとも安定して
いるようでした.私はapuをやめるようなことは起こらなかったよう
でした.
APUで以前YouTubeで稼いでいたよりも多くのお金を稼いでいます。
その上
、YouTubeのようなことをするのが好きです。APUは素晴らしい
大学で、特定の人にとって
はそこで働くのは本当に楽しいかもしれませんが、
個人的にはそこで働くのは好きではありませんでした。
学校は非常に
興味深く、非常にユニーク
ですが、
私は創造的な環境のようなものの方がはるかに優れて
おり、そのようなことは
簡単に言えば、人々が
あなたに何らかの抵抗を与え、
あなたが安全に行動できるようになることを期待しています.
あなたが今何をしている
か
st あなたがそれを我慢
できて、いわば嫌悪者を無視することができれば、
おそらくそれを実現することができるでしょう。だから
エリザベスと京都の aj
最初にエリザベスから京都
日本の職場は
特に
過労死に関して本当に厳しいです ええと、死に至るまで過労する
ことは、近年、それほど過酷な労働環境ではなくなり
、京都の aj
は、職場でのガイジンシートの性差別と
、学校でのいじめについて言っ
ています。これら 2 つの質問に答える最善の方法は、
日本は 単一のエンティティが好きではなく
、それが意味するの
は仕事
です.ある日本の会社は、
私が以前働いていた別の日本の会社とは根本的に異なる労働環境を持っているかもしれません.
労働
条件は実際にはかなり良いもの
でした.私は好きではありませんでした. そこで働い
ていたのは、私の性格に合わなかったからで
はなく、労働条件
が本当に
過酷で、過労だったからではありません。
毎日 9 時から 5 時まで働き
、時折有給の
残業
を
していました。それだけでした。知らなかったのです
が、大金を稼いでいたと思います。月に約 2,000 ドルを稼いでいたと思います。
職場環境です
が、私は東京のヘッドハンティング
会社で働いたことがあります。また、
いくつかの仕事も行ってい
ます。また、パフォーマンスに基づいて報酬を得るような、はるかに要求の厳しい翻訳も行っています。
その意味と
報酬はそれほど良く
ないので、あなたは
非常に非常に非常に一生懸命働かなければなら
ず、失敗すると叱責されるでしょう.
そのような状況では、私は職場
での性差別についてあまり知り
ませんが、学校でのいじめについては、
これも非常に状況に応じ
た
ものです。最初の質問に戻ると、
外国人や外国人の子供
もいたるところにいる
ので、
私の子供たちと同じように 現在行っている この
本当に素晴らしい学校に行きましたが
、その間に学校が変わったとしても、
実際には問題にならないことを私は知っています。なぜなら、ここの主要な公立学校のすべての学年ではないにしても、
少なくとも数
人の外国人
学生が
いるからです。 少なくともどの学校でも、私は
たくさんの逸話を読みました。
両親は
、
あなたが対処しなければならなかったことを知っています。おそらく
自分の髪のように、子供の髪の
色など、学校の方針とは一致しませんでした。
そして、
あなたは悪夢に次ぐ悪夢のように知っています。
繰り返しになりますが、
一般的に言えば、ここでは全面的にはるかに
厳しいと思い
ますが、私がいるベットブーツのような場所
では、日本にはたくさんのことがありますが、それに対処する必要はありませんでした。
日本に
は多くの異なる分野で改善の余地がたくさんあり
ます。皆さんが知っているこれらの問題の多くは
、人々
が日本に住み、日本で働き、日本で
子供を育てることを長期
的に考えたときに、かなり頻繁に思い浮かびます。
一部の人々が認識しているよりも少し状況に応じたものかもしれませんが、それ
は私自身の個人的な経験から話している
ので、一粒の
狂人であると考えてください。日本の留学生にとって最大の問題は何ですか？
バブルと
はつまり、もしあなたが
日本の留学生で、日本の
語学学校に行くか
、日本の大学に留学している
なら、あなたはおそらくバブルの中に
いることになるでしょう。
日本語を勉強している他の外国人留学生も
同じ
ような経験をしましたが、そのバブルから抜け出す唯一の方法
は
、自分がそれを所有し、
責任を負い、
私のように振る舞うことです。 これらの人々は私の友達です 彼らと一緒に過ごすのが大好きですが、
日本語がもっと上手になる必要があります
その意味で、彼らは
私を昼食に招待してくれました 行きたいです これらの
人々は素晴らしいですが、私は行くつもりです ダメって言って
あちらの日本人と話をして、一緒に
昼食をとれるかどうか試してみるつもりです.
両方のグループの友達がいるのは素晴らしいことだと思います
が、実際に出かけない場合は.
日本に留学しているときに日本人の友達を作ろうとする
あなたの方法は、留学の
途中で、
日本人の友達が1人か2人しか
いないと思います。
繰り返しになりますが、私自身の
経験から言えば、ほとんどの場合、
日本人の学生は英語も話せ
ます。その
ため、日本に来てすぐに彼らと友達になること
ができたのです。追加の努力
をしなければならず、それは簡単なことではありません。 快適
です 留学中に出会ったクールでクールな人々とたむろするのはとても簡単
です みんなみんなあなたのようだから みんな
やっと日本に来たばかり みんな本当に幸せ
彼らはとても興奮している 彼らは
皆興奮していて
、その意味で皆が同じボートに乗っていることを知っています。
皆さんはとてもポジティブで、
ああ、私たちはここにいますよ
、昼食に
出かけましょう。
とても楽しい
ですが、日本人と話そうとすると、
彼らは途中で好きになるかもしれません.
ヒップホップダンスサークルの
練習などを知っていると思います。
ここに交換留学生が
います 日本人の友達を作ろうとしています
私と一緒に昼食をとりませんか
？ 追加の努力は
快適ではありませんが
、私はその一人のようにそれをやろうとしまし
た.私が住んでいた寮を2、3人の学生が去ったと思います.1年間の留学中に
住んでいた国際寮.
ホームステイのオプションが
利用可能になった
ので、途中でホームステイを始めました。
できるだけ多くの日本語を使うようにしましたが
、この時点で 4 年間の成果があったと思います。それは
私の娘のような良い例
です。 ポケモンは今は寒くないし
、私が誤っ
て日本語で言ったように、これ
はバブルから抜け出すようなもの
で、娘たちが英語を上手にできるようにするための例です。
私はできません。 娘たちが日本語で会話を始めた
とき、
私はこれらのことをとても簡単に言う
ことができます.
日本語を話す 日本語で返事をしたいと思うのは自然なことです
が
、彼らが英語を
上手に話せる
ように、さらに努力をしなけれ
ばなりません。 日本語が上手
他の言語を話す可能性が
あり、そうしないことを選択したすべてのインスタンスすべてのやり取り お金を
節約する方法についての経験を聞くこと
に興味がある
通勤費 食費など 特定のレストランで外​​食しない、バーに行くなどの明白なこと
以外に、この点に関して何かヒントはありますか?
今はあまり詳しくは言えませんが、
新生銀行を強くお勧めします。
上位層のいずれかに到達した場合、
これ
はすでにここで働いていて貯金がある人により多く適用され
ます。その後
、地元の銀行や、711 ファミリーマート ローソン i などの地元のコンビニエンス ストアの ATM を使用できます。
ミニストップとかそういうの
もいつでも無料で使えるし、
日本は現金社会だから
現金が必要な時もあるからすごいね。  d
地方銀行のように使用している場合
特にチワワ イチョウ
のような地方銀行のようなもので、
あなたが知っている大分銀行
、長崎銀行、埼玉銀行などのような小さな
銀行の 1 つに似ています。 人々が銀行がどれだけのことを知らないという事実
は
、営業時間後にATMを使用することを知っているたびに彼らをぼった
くるようなもの
です.
ほとんどの人は、事後にすべてを合計するのに時間をかけません。
あなたがそうするなら、
私はこれをし
ました. これらの2つのフリコミのように支払う
私の従業員jpなどのように送金するなど
、それは男のようです
私はこれをできるだけ早くやめる必要があるので
、もしあなたが
外国人なら、彼らが最初に持っているSheen State Bankを調べてください. それが来ると、彼ら
はすべて非常に優れた
サービスを提供します
私たち
は外国人とよく仕事をしており、彼らは
実際
に私の新しい家のための私の新しい住宅ローンを
提供してくれました.
サービスも英語であり、
非常に競争力のある料金もあります わかり
ました これは私が
実際に
タイニーアブアブズタイニーアブスについて話すことを意味していた素晴らしい質問です 日本周辺で地震はどのくらいの頻度で発生します
か 特に
2週間前に起こった仙台での事件
私の 理論
では、日本は地震に非常に弱いため、日本の文化はある程度そのままであるということです。
先日読んだ統計によると、毎年
発生するすべての地震の 20 が
日本で発生し、それは日本が
原因であると私は信じています
3つの異なる地震またはum
構造プレート上に
あり、3つの異なる構造プレートの境界である
ため、
日本は
常に常にウィットに満ちて
います 地震のせいで、日本文化に
埋め込まれている一種の用心深さのお
役所仕事の
ような
ものは、物事をダブルチェック、トリプルチェックを何度も何度も何度も何度も何度も何度も何度も何度も何度も何度も繰り返しチェックし
た結果だと思います。
少なくとも 100 年ごとに 1 回は巨大
地震が発生し、
伝統的にその
ような大地震が発生しています。日本に住み
たい場合は、知っておくべきもう 1 つの良い点があり
ます。それについて知らない場合は、
これは uh nangkai torah と呼ば
れるもので、それがどういうことかというと
、
比較的近い将来に日本で巨大地震
が起こるだろうという
ことです
。 構造プレートには
海プレートがあり、次に陸プレート
とシード プレートがあり、陸
プレートの下に入り、ランプ プレートの下に下がると
、陸プレートを引っ張ります。
ランプ プレートが引き下げ
られると、最終的にそれが
元に戻るポイントに到達
します。ゴムバンドのようなもので、パチンと鳴る前に引っ張るだけです。これは
、これらのテクトニックと同じ方法です。
プレートには巨大な断層があり
、それは日本の南の国境全体を横切って爪を走り、
東京
からええと、海岸全体に沿って走るその横線の少し南のようなもの
です。  2030年代に巨大地震が起こると予想して
おり、2030年代
に起こらなければ、
ほぼ確実に2040年代に起こるだろう。それはいつ起こる
かの問題ではない.
日本の歴史
を見ると、
その断層に沿った大地震が 300 年ごとに発生していることが
わかります。ちょうど今ちょうど
その 300 年を迎えよ
うとしています。
実際に
は 3 つの異なる
断層が
あり
、100 年または 150 年ごと
にそのうちの 1 つが
地震を
引き起こします。なぜなら、陸塊が後退するからです。しかし、300 年ごとに
3 つすべてが一度に元に戻り
ます。  1700年代に日本
で巨大な巨大地震があり
、それはすべて日本
の南の国境を越えていたように呼ばれていると思い
ます.
それは
日本がこれまでに記録した中で最大の地震だったか、
またはその直後の
2番目の地震だったと思います. ええと
、311 の地震が
11 年前の 3 年前に再び発生しました。この時点
で、2 週間前に仙台で発生した事件はどれほど一般的
ですか。 その間、少なくとも5年は経験する
でしょう。おそらく
、どこに住んでいるかに関係なく、
少なくとも1回は、それほど危険ではなくても恐怖を感じるほど大きな地震が発生すると
思います。 怖がる
ほど大きな地震を少なくとも 1 回体験
することはでき
ません。この時点で 2 回
、妻が近くの街のこの場所で働いていまし
た。私が怖がっていた地震が
起こったときは、とても大きかったです。
彼女が働いていた場所はその
最中に破壊され、事後に建物を破壊しなければなり
ませんでした。修復するものが多すぎて
、ゼロから始める方がよかったので
、彼らはこれを行ったのが一般
的です。 長い目で見れば、日本に住んで
いるなら、伝統的な
日本の
町家のような伝統的な日本の京都の
ような町屋やそのような
ものに引っ越すよりも、適切なアパートのようなものに引っ越す方がおそらくはるかに安全です. ロマン主義のような特定の要素が
ありますが、おそらくあまり安全ではなく
、100 年前のように建設された
建物の
規制が
まったく異なる場所には行きたくありません。 今後 15 年以内に大地震が起こる
と思いますが
、日本での仕事について
何かお勧めはありますか 2 ～ 3 年はそこに住んで
みてください。
英語を話せればチャンスはたくさんあり
ます。特に英語を母国
語とする人であれば、日本に 2、3 年住んで
ここで英語を教える
こと
ができます。 ジェットプログラム
で大学を卒業してすぐにできるようなスキル
と、ジェットプログラムに参加できない
場合は、ジェットプログラムの他の代替手段
のいずれかに応募する
か、場所によっては可能です。
あなたは仕事の休日のように試してみて
、小さな私立の英語
教育学校などに行く
ことができ
ます。あなたが大卒であれば、そうするのはそれほど難しくありませ
ん 難しい o
日本に 2、3 年
しか住ん
で
いない場合は、英語教育に
代わるものを見つけ
ます。
リンクインのようなオンライン プラットフォームが利用可能であるにもかかわらず、設定会に参加することは非常に重要だと
思います。彼ら
は外人向けのマーケティング スラッシュ セールス ポジションをその場で
魔界に提供
していますか? 長い間、この種のビデオの 1 つと
、それ
が一般的な日本経済の一種で
ある悲しい真実は、
日本の経済はうまくいっていないという
ことであり、バブル後 30 年ほどはうまくいっていません。
ポスト
大学または大卒者の平均レートは
2,000
くらいで
、30 年間約 2,000 で推移しており、現在も変わっていません。
昔、
平均的な大卒者
が卒業直後に稼ぐ金額は、
日本を上回っていました。日本は韓国に追い抜か
れました。ご存知のように、
ほとんどの西側諸国は
ほぼ間違いなく、
信じられないほどの成長を遂げている東南アジア諸国のすべてです。 現在、
マレーシア・
インドネシアのように
、彼らの多くは
まだその2000ドルに完全に追いついていませんが、
彼らは非常に急速に成長して
おり、彼らの多くが最終的に
日本を追い抜くのは時間の問題です. あなた
は日本の会社に行って働きます. たとえ先に述べた
ように労働条件が良くても.
apuでの労働条件は良好でし
た. 日本で
月に 2,000 稼いでいると、お金を節約するのは非常
に難しく、残念なことに 20代
の圧倒的多数の
人や30代の多くの人が
月に2000～3000ドル
稼いでいるのはそれ
です. 元の質問
は、日本の企業が何を求めているか知っているようなものでした
.ほとんどの
人はこれを聞きたくないだろうと言いました.
これはおそらくあなたが聞きたいアドバイスではありませ
んが、私はそれが最善のアドバイスだと思います
つまり、伝統的な日本企業のように
キャリアを確保しようとするのは、長期的には良いことではないと思い
ます
例 私は今エルドン リングをプレイしています エルドン リングは
フロム ソフトウェアによって開発され
、その後バンダイナムコによって公開されまし
た
エルドン リングが出た後、1200 万部か何かのように販売されたと思います
l
バンダイナムコはすぐに振り向いて
、従業員の賃金を全面的に引き上げると言いました。覚えて
いないのはエンジニアだけだったのかもしれませんが、これだけの数
だったようです。
賃金を 30% 引き上げる
か、そのよう
な会社で働きたいと思っていました。
もう少し、それほど厳格ではありません。そのような会社を見つけることが
できれば、それが
日本の会社であっても、外国の会社でなくても、日本
で本当に良い会社になる可能性があります
。ズームアウトするのが最善だと思います
ズームアウト
ほとんどの人にとってそれが一番良いことだ
と思います ズームアウトして考えます 本当に
日本企業で働きたいですか 日本
経済は30年間成長していません
この時点
で私は日本企業で働きたいですか 伝統的な
日本の会社多分私は欲しい
もう少し柔軟な日本の会社で働くには
、もう少しダイナミック
で、従業員に十分な報酬を支払う
か、日本にある外資系企業で働きたいか
、日本でフリーランスをやりたいか、柔軟で
意欲的であること いくらかのリスクを冒し
てください。そうすれば、報われる可能性が十分にあると思います。
私が apu に
とどまることを選択していたとしても
、私と妻の 4 人家族で月に 2,000 ドル稼いでいたでしょう。 私の2人の女の子と
それは簡単ではないでしょう.それは非常に非常に難しいでしょう.
しかし、
私はリスクを
冒すことに決めまし
た. 報われた後、
私はリスクを冒して、今はまだ
YouTubeでapuにいるほど多くは稼いでいないと言いました
が、apuをやめ
て、これに傾倒し、
それを機能させました 私は星
が私にとって非常にうまく整列していてとても幸運でしたが、それがリグだと思います
日本の過去 30 年間の経済動向を
考えると、多くの人にとって ht の選択だと思います。おそらく、このビデオを終了するのに適した場所だと
思います。比較的近い将来、いくつかのかなり
メジャーなアップデートが実際に行われます。
家に関連するものもあります。 私がここで構築していること
は、このビデオの前半で述べたと思います
が、その間におそらく 4 つまたは 5 つのコメディ ビデオになる
予定です。とりとめのないので、
ここでビデオを終了し
ます。 サポートしてください。またすぐにお会いしましょう
。